The end of the world is a topic as old as
the world itself.
As long as we have lived, we’ve realized
that all this has to come to a stop someday.
It’s just a question of when, of how, and
of whether there’s anything we can do about
it.
There are thousands upon thousands of different
interpretations of how exactly it will all
come to an end.
Some say it ends with a bang; a massive flood,
a plague of locusts, a rain of fire.
Some say it ends with a whimper; the quiet
death of all life, the stars winking out all
at once, the world going to sleep one day
and never waking back up.
So how does it all end?
Well, like many great tragedies, Achilles
felled by a single arrow, a tiny tremor becoming
a deadly tsunami, or a tiny molecule bringing
the end for billions, it begins with something
small.
Something seemingly insignificant.
It begins with a Lock.
In 1654, a minor Scottish aristocrat named
Sir Edwin Young was traveling across the Mesopotamian
desert in search of something most unusual.
He was eager to find a new item for his Cabinet
of Curiosities, a room in his home filled
with bizarre discoveries from all around the
globe.
Sculptures of twisted beasts, pickled creatures
gazing lifelessly from jars, and jewels plucked
from the - likely cursed - tombs of long-dead
royalty.
On this particular trip, he found his favorite
item yet, which he described in his journals
as a “bound jewel of onyx and filigree gold,
of fineness beyond rational statement.”
It was found in an ancient ruin, thought to
be the temple of “a fearsome death god.”
Though Sir Young seemed to understand the
gravity of his discovery, he had no idea what
he had found, or that it was yet another world-altering
instance of SCP-001.
SCP-001 is a complicated topic, one we’ve
covered on here many times before.
Every time you think you understand exactly
what it means, there’s a new curveball coming
directly at your face.
There are nightmarish monsters, a sun that’s
turned against all human life, more secret
origins for the Foundation and perhaps all
life than you can even count on your fingers,
a guardian with a flaming sword, a great red
monarch hoping to bring an end to all light
and happiness in the multiverse, and now there’s
SCP-001 The Lock, or qntm’s proposal.
After Young’s death, his descendants donated
his collection to the Scottish National Museum.
There, a curator named Mr. McCandlish was
able to translate Runic sketches in Young’s
notes, identified as Tertiary Sumerian Cuneiform
circa 3400 BCE.
Though they could not be fully translated,
the words “with loss” “Apakht” “ending”
“joy” and “permanence” were identified.
In 2003, the SCP Foundation discovered the
item and brought it in for further study.
The Lock is a small smooth, black, ellipsoidal
onyx stone with a white pattern that resembles
the cosmic microwave background, a pattern
of microwaves mapped by NASA that encompasses
the entire known universe.
The stone is wrapped in complex layers of
gold filigree, which cover the stone’s center
as well as both the top and bottom.
At the top of the stone, the pattern of the
gold becomes too complex for the human eye
to grasp, and even defies resolution using
a microscope.
This is thought to be the “keyhole”, as
it were, or the point at which The Lock could
become unlocked.
The thing about locks is that they tend to
hold secrets.
They almost always have something valuable
to hide.
And anything that can be locked can be unlocked,
as long as you have the right key.
The Foundation tried a variety of methods
to open The Lock, with no success.
Ordinary lock-picking techniques were futile,
as were attempts to open it with a hammer,
chisel, sledgehammer, bolt-cutters, welding
torch, or bandsaw.
Extreme heat, industrial cutting lasers, car
crushers, acid, plastic explosives, and even
an atomic warhead had no effect whatsoever.
Dr. Hack terminated efforts to unlock The
Lock, also known as Project Pluto, on the
grounds that it was a fool’s errand, better
at wasting Foundation resources than producing
productive results.
However, Dr. Mirski, who took over the research
team after Dr. Hack’s departure, resumed
the Project.
They should have stopped trying to open it.
Perhaps, if they had known what was waiting
to be released, what Apakht truly meant, they
would have…
In the lowest, most secure levels of Site
10, Dr. Yara Mirski held The Lock in her gloved
hands, feeling its heat pulse through the
latex.
She was inspecting its intricate gold filigree,
looking at the place where a key should fit,
and pondering their many attempts to unlock
it.
Nothing had worked yet, and perhaps that was
for the best.
Though her colleagues were uncomfortable with
the idea of something that could not be unlocked,
a code that refused to be cracked, she had
the distinct feeling that an item that couldn’t
be opened by even the blast of a nuclear weapon
might be hiding something even deadlier.
But she didn’t have time to finish that
thought.
A horn blared, shattering her concentration
and alerting her to the coming disaster.
It was a warning, a sign that something had
breached containment.
Only it wasn’t something trying to break
out.
It was something breaking in.
Hurriedly, she sat down the lock and opened
a hatch in the floor, removing a harpoon gun,
outfitted especially for taking on powerful
anomalous enemies.
She knew that the Harbinger was coming.
There was little else she knew about the thing,
but she was certain that it was here for The
Lock, here to open it and usher in whatever
would come after.
She loaded a bolt into the harpoon gun and
prepared for its arrival.
Then, all at once, there it was: glowing with
brilliant white light, almost too bright to
look at.
It was shaped like a human being, but she
couldn’t see its face.
She couldn’t look at it for too long without
her head aching.
A hundred wings sprouted from its back like
a biblical angel, its light permeating the
once-dimly lit chamber.
She was a researcher, not trained for combat,
but there was no other choice when she was
all that stood between The Lock and this otherworldly
being.
She closed her eyes tight, and she squeezed
the trigger.
The bolt flew and plunged directly into the
being’s chest.
The Harbinger watched her.
Though she could not see its eyes, she felt
its gaze boring into her as it reached up
with one hand, and broke the harpoon into
pieces like it was nothing.
It tossed the pieces to the side, now useless.
Not knowing what else to do, overcome with
awe and terror, Dr. Mirski collapsed onto
her knees.
“Cut that out.”
The Harbinger said, urging her back to her
feet.
It promised that it would not kill her.
As she stared, open-mouthed, it produced a
small, simple object: a key.
Dr. Mirski pleaded with the being, asking
it to reconsider, to think about what might
be waiting inside The Lock.
If the Harbinger had a visible mouth, it would
have smiled.
It told her that it knew exactly what was
inside.
It was Apakht, and it would be released.
As she watched, helpless, the Harbinger pushed
the key into the lock and turned.
There was a flash of light, unbearably bright
and quick, the feeling of everything changing
across the world all at once.
Suddenly, the being before her was not a creature
of wings and light, but a person.
A person she almost recognized…but couldn’t,
like the Harbinger had a hold on her mind,
and wouldn’t let her access the memory.
“Sorry.
Nothing personal,” It said, as its form
shifted back to that painful brilliance.
“What did you do?”
Dr. Mirski asked.
“What did you unlock?
What’s Apakht?”
The Harbinger answered simply: “It’s the
End.”
Soon after Dr. Mirski met the Harbinger and
watched it open The Lock, a man named Freddie
Jones was hunting snakes near Tampa, Florida.
A one thousand dollar prize had been promised
to the man who killed the longest python,
and fifteen hundred dollars were guaranteed
to the man who killed more pythons than anyone
else.
Just days before, Freddie had been filling
up his truck at the local gas-n-go when he
stopped to watch the longest python he had
ever seen in his life slither across the asphalt
and into the nearby swamp.
That was a surefire way to win if he’d ever
seen one, and now he was making his way across
the wet, springy ground of the swamp in search
of his prize.
After two hours of tramping through the wilderness,
all he had to show for it was a few kingsnakes
and some black racers.
No pythons yet, and certainly not the extra-long
beast he’d seen before.
He was getting close to giving up, hot, exhausted,
covered in bites from fire ants, when he saw
it: smooth scaly skin, winding through the
underbrush.
He’d know that pattern anywhere.
He snapped back into hunter mode, trailing
the creature as fast as he could.
His heart thumped against his chest and he
reminded himself his cardiologist said to
avoid strenuous exercise, but he’d already
come this far.
No giving up now.
His father hadn’t raised a quitter.
Above him, a storm was brewing, thick clouds
gathering as thunder shook the ground and
lightning flashed uncomfortably close.
He had to move fast.
There was no doubt about it, his time out
there was limited.
He was right about this, but not for the reason
he thought.
He stumbled as the ground quaked, trying to
keep on his feet.
The python was still in his eyeline, looking
longer and bigger as he got closer.
He weaved through the tall grass, looking
for the snake’s head.
He took six steps, then six more.
There was no sign of its head yet.
This thing was even bigger than he’d thought!
No way anyone else was taking home that cash.
He felt his stomach drop as he realized that
he still couldn’t find the snake’s head.
Its body stretched on and on, weaving all
around the brush.
It was everywhere, and it was somehow…growing.
He pointed his rifle at one side, where the
snake’s body had grown to the size of a
horse.
That was impossible, he had to be seeing things,
but there it was.
He squeezed the trigger and fired, the sound
lost in the thunder.
The snake didn’t even react.
It grew larger and thicker, winding around
him as he turned in circles trying to track
it.
He didn’t even see the enormous head rising
over him.
At least, until it blocked out the sun.
He opened his mouth to scream, but was crushed
beneath the body of the massive snake as it
slithered through the swamp, crushing plants
and animals as it went.
Freddie Jones was not the only person to see
something strange at that moment, and he would
not be the last.
A change was coming, and it was coming faster
than anyone could keep up with.
In South Dakota, the king of the bears clawed
his way up from the earth with paws the size
of trucks.
A massive beast from the deep crushed a tour
boat off the shores of New England.
A buffalo the size of a mountain shook itself
awake on the Great Plains.
Across the world, from above and below and
beyond it, something was coming.
An unknowable number of things, in fact.
Entities from beyond the stars, from the ocean
floor, from the earth’s crust and mouse
holes in provincial homes.
There were some that loved humanity, some
that hated it, some that could barely remember
what it was.
Another was from the SCP Foundation itself,
someone who was not supposed to exist.
None of them were, really.
But they all did, and they were all coming
to see what would happen next.
This story is only just beginning…because
it wasn’t just one apocalypse that was unleashed
with the opening of The Lock.
It was all of them.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks”
and “SCP-001 - The Scarlet King” for more
apocalyptic accounts of SCP-001!